Okay, so, how man do you want to look at?
>> Well in this case it, you know, I feel like I could draw a, a
kind of extended city block zone and capture
maybe, I don't know, five of the points.
>> Okay, let's do it. So let's find our
five, our five nearest neighbors. So let's see. This is
clearly close, that's one over here. I'd
say this is close. I'll say this one is close. This one's close.
None of the other blue ones are actually that close. And I'd
say that's the next closest one, so here are my little five points.
That all seem relative near. So what does that tell you?
>> Well, I mean, it's, it feels like it
suggests that red is not a bad choice here.
>> Mm
>> It's in a reddish part of town.
>> Yeah, I get that. So, so you think it's a
pretty, fair thing to bet that this should be red then?
>> Yeah I mean I think that if you were really asking me seriously
I would wonder about that blue point to the right of the highway and whether
that had any influence.
>> That's pretty far away.
>> Yeah, it's not that far away.
>> Well in Atlanta, once you cross highways
you might as well be an infinite distance away.
>> Well so, okay, but. That's a good point then.
So, I guess I was interpreting your notion of distance as
being, you know, like straight line distance on the map. But
maybe that doesn't make sense for this kind of neighborhood example.
>> Hm, no, that's a good point. So,
we've been talking about distance sort of implicitly.
But this notion of distance. It's actually quite important. So maybe distance is
straight-line distance, maybe it's as the crow
flies. Maybe it's driving distance. Maybe it
has to take into account the fact that, when you cross highways in
Atlanta, you're typically moving into a completely
different universe. These sorts of things matter.
>> Yeah. So I could imagine I don't know, like Google Maps distance.
>> Right. Or how many paths can you get there
and which is the shortest one given the traffic? There's all
kinds of things like that you could do. So. So that's
fair, that's fair. But that just says that this, this distant, we
have to be very careful what we mean by distance and
that's okay. But let's just say for the sake of this discussion
that these are the closest points by some reasonable measure of
distance. So, in that world, would you be happy if you had
to pick a single example? a single output, a single label
of red ,uh, blue or green. Would you be happy picking red?
>> Yeah, I
mean you know, not ecstatic, but okay.
>> That's fair. So, I like this. So, we, we
went from just picking our nearest neighbor to picking our nearest
neighbors. And ,what's a good value you think we should,
we should stick to with neighbors? We started with one and
that clearly wasn't good. You picked, at least not in
all cases and you came up with five. So what do
you think? What, what, if I'm going to call this algorithm something,
what do you think five nearest neighbors? What do you think?
What should I call it?
>> Five seems good. I mean I feel like that, that's gotta be universal.
>> The number five?
>> Yeah.
>> Well it is in Atlanta but it might
not be univeral in wherever it is you are.
>> We'll call it the Georgia Tech nearest neighbors.
>> That doesn't seem like an algorithm that's going to to be used very much.
>> Fair enough. All right. So what about,
we could do as many nearest neighbors as
is appropriate. Or maybe we should just make it a free parameter and call it K.
>> Ok, I like that. K nearest neighbors, so we'll have K
nearest neighbors. And we'll pick our K numbers. Oh, and you said
something fancy there, by the way. You said free parameter. I like
that. We should, we should come back to that again. So we
have an algorithm, k nearest neighbors. Which takes K nearest neighbors as
a way of deciding how you're going to label some query point here.
And we've identified two parameters to the algorithm so far. K Which
is the number of neighbors we're going to use. And some notion of distance.
>> Oh, sure.
>> Which
here we were kind of using in the sort of obvious way,
but there might be other ways we might want to use distance here.
>> Yeah, like I could imagine if the houses, if,
had additional features like how many Square footages they had.
>> Right, stuff like that. That would make perfect sense.
So, so really distance, we're using distance here in a kind
of in an over loaded sense, because this is something
on a map. But really distance is a standard for similarity.
>> Similarity, good. It's kind of standard
for the opposite of similarity.
>> [LAUGH] Well distance is just a kind of similarity, right?
But in case of, you know, points on the map. Similarity,
it sort of makes sense because as you said when we
were talking about real estate, location,
location, location matters. So, there, similarity
really is kind of the inverse of distance. But in other
ways, things like the number of veterans you have, whether you're
one on side of the highway or the other, the school
district you're in, things like that, are other things you might add
as features or dimensions when you talk about similarity or distance.
Okay, so I like this. I think we have a general algorithm
now and I think it does a pretty good job of
addressing the points you brought up. We no longer have to worry
about overfitting as much, at least it seems that way to
me. And we have a way of being a little bit more
robust to this, you know, not having an exact data point
in the database. So ,maybe we should turn this into an algorithm.
>> Yeah,
let's go for it.
>> Okay, let's do that.